bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
alors on le sait une première visite en
france car c'est une tradition mais ce
n'est pas pour autant que cette visite
doit être considéré comme un simple
royal protocolaire non effectivement je
pense que les les deux responsables sont
plus proches que ne l'était emmanuel
macron et madame merkel
ça n'empêche pas qu'il ya des désaccords
sur le fond mais ils sont tellement
nette que ça ne tient à rien en pro d2
sud il ya le désaccord sur le nucléaire
n'est pas ce que pense monsieur chansons
de lui-même mais il est lié ou
d'écologistes et il est dans une
situation difficile du fait ne feront
plus clair alors que la france est plus
bon continuant chez dans ce domaine
la deuxième question c'est celle des
finances puisque le gouvernement de
coalition et le ministre des finances
c'était un libéral et pour une ample
d'auxi budgétaire alors que la france
n'est pas vraiment vraiment dans le
domaine
jusque là que je pense que tout le monde
le sait est que le sentiment européen
des deux côtés va pousser a quand même
bonne entente globale en maintenant je
vais parler de mes réactions un peu
personnel alors la première c'était une
question d'actualité mais qui n'est pas
tellement dans la grande presse quelle
impression les langues à volstead il se
trouve que les langues de travail
d'accueil des traités signés et pas
respecté son l'anglais le français et
l'allemand
depuis que des anglais sont partis en
pole salle il ya beaucoup moins de
raisons ils utilisent et d'anglais quand
il est utilisé c'est bizarre vie des
peuples concernés à l'intérieur vous le
savez parle la langue qu'elle veut mais
quand j'ai fait faire des achats des
français sakho est en français donc il
s'agit d'un vrai cela les allemands
allaient être un allemand c'est dans des
traités j'espère qu'ils vont progresser
sur ce quoi alors on va être on est
pressé par le temps suis vraiment désolé
donc selon vous aussi vous nous vous
nous disiez en tant que manuel m'apprend
était plus proche en tout cas de belles
choses qui ne l'étaient d'angela merkel
ça veut dire qu'on a un nouveau chapitre
peut-être qui s'ouvre dans cette amitié
franco allemande
alors logiquement oui ou plusieurs
raisons d'abord la france est en
meilleure position avant elle était
souvent en position faible censé
s'occuper moins efficacement du virus
ans et les taux d'utilisation économique
plus faible aujourd'hui la france va le
mieux et l'allemagne va moins bien donc
je dirais que de poids respectifs se
sont à peu rapproché
deuxièmement cette coalition est un peu
moins soumis ce que celle de merkel
aux pressions des industriels hors dia
de finalement ils sont des gens
remarquables et efficace etc ont
tendance à oublier des problèmes
politiques et à ne parler que des
questions d'affaires que tu as fait leur
boulot
donc cette coalition devrait être un
petit peu moins proche des milieux
d'affaires temps restant assez proches
et ça devrait aussi simplifier beaucoup
de choses
alors on serre la france va prendre la
présidence de l'union européenne ce sera
dans un peu plus de vingt jours 20 ans
jour je crois manuel macron l'a dit ils
veulent repenser le cadre budgétaire de
l'europe c'est possible seulement si
l'allemagne est d'accord
n'est pas que j'ai compris je suis
désolé
macron qui va prendre la présidence de
l'union européenne il a des grands
projets dont repenser le cadre
budgétaire de l'europe il pourra le
faire seulement si l'accord de
l'allemagne bien sûr bien sûr je crois
que la bonne volonté existe les deux
côtés il ya une proximité à taille
actuelle 1 de fait un peu piquant mais
ça ne va pas se fier à tout résoudre le
padd est tout à l'heure du nucléaire des
divergences sont profondes
monsieur montée merci en tout cas
d'avoir été avec nous et d'avoir répondu
à nos questions je rappelle que vous
êtes enseignant en géopolitique écrivain
merci